I have friends who make $42,000 a year
work N9 to four but they're pumped and
they'll text me like how happy they are
to be the coach of their kids baseball
team and you know that's amazing I'm
actually weirdly envious but I have
friends who have $100 million in the
bank who are still hungry who want to do
even more who will complain to me cuz
they know I work a lot about no work
life balance and they don't get to spend
enough time with their family and I'm
like you have $100 million you could
stay home like you're in control don't
complain about it you've made that
choice you want to spend more time with
your family spend more time with your
family